friday upon us a lot of us looking for
the best and the newest kitchen gadgets
and who else to help us but our good
friend dr frank vigiano hey good morning
dr frank
good morning nate how are you my friend
of course i am mostly sunny how are you
same here okay so i know we're starting
out with uh something in the kitchen
that folks may not necessarily think of
as a gift but might be very helpful in
the kitchen
so kenneth has basically brought out the
resp kitchen fire extinguisher but the
sad part nate is only 25
of us households have a kitchen
extinguisher currently
and kita has the only ul listed fire
extinguisher for use with residential
cooking equipment it has a unique
specially designed nozzle which
dispenses in an arc instead of a
straight stream the arc minimizes the
chance of oil splashing and basically
spreading the fire and it also uses the
non-toxic agent similar to baking soda
that doesn't damage appliances available
for only
this is the deal 1995 at walmart it's a
no-brainer you can find other models
available at home depot amazon and also
shopkitted.com but this is a must mate
this is something that everybody should
have in their kitchen i agree now i
cannot help but notice there's a it
looks like a giant blender on your table
there dr frank what's that about
yeah yes it is a giant blender it's by
braun it's their triforce power blender
it blends 60 percent faster and four
times finer than other products on the
market it has 18 different food programs
made that let you automate texture to
coarse medium or smooth and it has
precision edge blades that are forged
and sold soldien germany that's
important and they emulsify even hearty
root vegetables what i like the most
though is a hot soup function it turns
cold veggies into warm soups with
passive heat there's a clean function as
well just take a few drops of soap put
it in with some water and in seconds you
can clean it it starts at 239.95
available at brownhousehold.com
walmart target and amazon i'm gonna have
to check that one out because i don't
know if you know this drink but i make
my own mayonnaise at home and you need a
good blender for that
oh you'll love this thing this is so
powerful all right okay so one more
thing on the table there what is fusion
for home
well you know everybody's home i'm home
i have my home studio here talking with
you in las vegas and the most important
thing is you know internet and wi-fi
capability and this is the best signal
booster for cell phones that works with
all north american carriers att verizon
t-mobile sprint it doesn't matter but
they maintain a reliable indoor signal
so it improves sell signals for 4g
lte
5g nationwide voice text and data so it
gets it all so the model is perfect you
can put it in yourself if you want you
can install it but professional
installation is available and basically
we're installing homes up to 5000 square
feet which is amazing and it
significantly reduces drop in this calls
it increases data speed so anybody
streaming this is this is ideal it's
what you really want it has a three year
lifetime warranty nate it's based here
in the us and it's made here in the us
and it's designed and assembled by
surecall.com they have a black friday
special which is very unique 40 off the
regular price is
it on sale for 499.99
that's a 200 savings and it's available
at amazon.com wow that is a real deal
especially for folks who have that
problem of phone calls or yours your
cell service or even your video service
dropping out on you
no question you know it's very common i
get calls and emails all the time from
my viewers and this product is amazing
and the key is it'll improve wi-fi by 20
times can you imagine that wow hey dr
frank always good talking to you we
can't wait to see you in person here in
las vegas for the consumer electronics
show in january safe holidays to you my
friend
likewise same to you nate i'll see you
in january